completely
[Music]
okay uh so on on this key no longer but
uh you have to be in the back you're
never in the front do you see that don't
be in the front so let's first correct
that okay they're not over here like
this and then you're here in the front
okay
you're gonna be
in the Box
home and you're under he never is
looking at you okay now this is the
footwork
don't go back behind him
okay he's on a different spiral and I
want to keep him on the spiral and we're
gonna go this way
oh
this way
okay again on the
throw
the head
is going around me
and the hip is going to the other angle
okay
so
um
here see I'm ready for the head Tristan
then I'm here
move around
there's your hit
you see if I don't want to grab the arm
there's no need the hip is your throat
boom
okay if he's if he blocks me I can't get
in here I'll adhere on the wrist not
grab it and I'll still project through
the hip okay
[Music]
all right let's try
this okay
here
and I don't want to go here
then you think you're going to push him
again his face
right but every every okay all over the
world goes ahead and goes there but he's
in the he's in a good base his defensive
linemen doing this pretty much you see
okay so instead
you're gonna adhere whatever you have
that moves that moves together with you
I'm not grabbing it I'm just stuck to it
I moved out you see I moved out right I
need to go over this way with his head
and then the hip goes that way this way
with his head and the hip goes around
something else
as we're here
boom
don't cut
against his grip
don't go this way
why are you going like this
now he's strong there
do you see
so when you're here like this you reach
out
do you think you're over here and you're
on the other side
cutting down and then the idea you need
it
so watch How I am going to spill over
that
boom
boom there it is
and that's where it drops
adhesion around hip
so there he's he blocked my arm so I use
the arm for the projection okay
oh
oh there it is
I'm on the other side of it
adhesion comes with me
okay
so it's
right it looks like you're gonna go long
and then pull that guy back that's what
you guys are thinking like you're
pulling the guys out
what you what you're going to do instead
is not
pull him back I'm gonna go here you see
and then touch your head excuse me and
then from these two points
get ready you don't I don't even need
your grip open up your grip okay from
these two points I move your body you
see
I don't need to grab your
and move your body from here
[Music]
your body comes with me
you feel that
I feel a bit different
and that's what's happening half the
time right and then the UK has to be
like some alphabetic
choreographed
Okay so
we'll slow it back down
okay
instead of touch you see I'm not gonna
fall I'm not pulling your grip we move
together with the adhesion
okay
I want you to open so you know I don't
I'm not using your grips okay the
adhesion moves you okay are you the
adhesion we're going to move together
okay
so instead of feeling that
try to not feel that
try to not feel them you see try to
knock you
okay